con la meta a la vista ambos candidatos
están intentando ganar apoyo de cara a
las elecciones del próximo martes
fieles a su nombre los valor grano
states los estados en disputa o
pendulares es en donde se enfrentan
ahora job aire y donald trump el ex
presidente barack obama estuvo buscando
votos en florida mientras fijamos las
aves acudió a nevada con bailén haciendo
dos paradas en georgia un estado en
donde ningún demócrata ha ganado desde
1992 pero los sondeos lo sitúan
ligeramente a la cabeza
amigos es momento de levantarnos y
recuperar nuestra democracia y un lugar
en donde podemos hacer eso es georgia si
ganamos en georgia ganamos todos
la agenda de donald trump estuvo
apretada con el mandatario haciendo
presencia en mítines sin distanciamiento
social en michigan wisconsin y nebraska
y es que hay trabajo por hacer si las
encuestas están en lo cierto
su victoria en estados clave como
michigan wisconsin parece estar
diluyéndose con un baile que estaría
arriba por unos 5 puntos
el magnate asegura que esos sondeos son
falsos y espera volver a ganar next way
course carstens que la próxima semana
wisconsin va a responder
de la historia ustedes van a ver una
gran ola roja el martes
van a ver una gran ola roja como la que
nunca han visto antes una muy grande y
mi ford más de 69 millones de
estadounidenses ya han votado de manera
anticipada una cifra récord casi la
mitad a todos los votantes que hubo en
2016 y con los comicios a menos de una
semana de distancia
los aspirantes saben que cualquier voto
en los estados pendulares importa el
ganador de las anteriores elecciones fue
resultado de poco menos de 80.000 votos
en sólo tres de estos estados